what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch money
right i'm here with the beautiful
intelligent pelina ebilova
marinova pompliano you already know what
the deal is don't forget that lunch
money is now sponsored by block five
bang bang let's go get block five
accounts block five dot com slash pomp
you can go and what you can do is you
can earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account
you can buy and sell crypto on a crypto
exchange with no fees
and you can also deposit crypto and take
out of us. alone and get your crypto
collateral
i'm an investor i sit on the board i'm a
happy user and so will you go to
blockbuy.com
again blockfy.com
what's up hi hello hello let's go let's
go let's go
to you to my people um bitcoins value
passed one trillion dollars this weekend
the price sword pass 56 000 pass 57 000
are we at 58 000 yet
the price did not go past 1 trillion the
market cap
i said the price went past 56 000.
did you know he's not listening guys uh
did it go past 58 000.
it did at one point but then it fell off
a cliff this morning
what how how far did it go down it hit
49 000. but like i tell you guys
dollar cost average hold for a long
period of time
don't be invested more money than you
can lose keep a long time horizon it's
super volatile
stop looking at the price that's it
that's the whole key to this game
but a trillion dollars a big deal very
high psychological bar to cross over
because now all of a sudden people like
oh wow it's a trillion dollars
i probably should go take a look at this
this looks like it's pretty interesting
it's getting big enough
bitcoin is probably the only asset i can
think of as the price goes up it becomes
more attractive to institutional
investors
and remember one trillion is the market
cap not the price
okay um moving on you need to bring that
monday energy
bringing that nonsense up in here yeah
let me bring that
garbage that garbage go ahead oh my god
he's screaming
tesla has made about one it's not
because you can hear this
tesla has made about one
he's spitting his phone stop spinning
your phone
okay tesla has made about one billion
dollars in profit on its bitcoin
investment um on paper
uh but in the company is on a trajectory
to make more from its bitcoin
investments than
profits from selling its electric
vehicle cars in
all of 2020. wow what do we think about
that
this is old news i tweeted this a week
ago
they made 721 based on the appreciation
of their bitcoin
uh 721 million dollars in appreciation
and last year they made 725 million
dollars in profit
so not only were they about to eclipse
it but now that they're
close to a billion well now not because
the price fell but
a billion dollars in appreciation the
big one's gonna be when it doubles they
bought around thirty three thousand
dollars so about sixty six thousand
dollars
everyone's gonna be like oh we should
have done the same thing
and all those people are going to buy 66
000 and then it's gonna double for them
it's gonna be great it's gonna be
amazing um
okay great are we done yes all right so
jp morgan
is thinks that bitcoin is an economic
side show the despite its monstro rally
um according to jp morgan the rise of
digital finance is the real financial
transformation story of the covet 19
era so they're betting on fintech
they're not betting on
bitcoin specifically long bitcoin short
the bankers that's what i think
you know why this is stupid why it's
because
most people can't invest
in the fintech companies stop
dangling all this nonsense in front of
people
and just reiterating the fact that
because of accreditation loss
the opportunities to invest in that
market are not available to the everyday
person yeah that's true people can't
invest
in the fintech startups until those
startups are public companies
but they can invest in bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies correct
correct and on top of that most of the
fintechs
square paypal etc
they're benefiting from bitcoin
robinhood all of them
so you can't say that uh oh it's a
fintech story it's like blockchain not
bitcoin
fintech not bitcoin how about world
not jp morgan all right hennessy
the wine and spirits division of luxury
conglomerate lvmh
announced monday the purchase of a 50
stake in jay-z's champagne
brand armand de brignac did i say that
right i don't know
uh terms of the deal were not disclosed
but look at all them celebrities
having their whiskey champagne
jay-z's the pioneer though ace of spades
wait what you know when you're in the
club and ace of spades comes out
everyone's like
oh the brand is known as ace of spades
wow it sold more than 500 000 bottles in
2019
with fewer parties and nights out the
pandemic has hit
champagne sales but do not
mourn sorry listen ace of spades
costs 13 to make one three
they sell it for like 225 to the club
and then the club marks it up another
like 50
so you the club are paying like 300 and
something dollars don't be paying 300
something dollars at the club
order me some aces fades to the house
champagne
i might come on lunch money and pop a
bottle of ace of spades
if you want to see me do that leave a
comment and we get enough comments
she will let me do it no because we
haven't drank anything since january
1st 2021 any alcoholic adult beverages
ain't no better way to break the streak
than with ace of spades what up
j z go ahead do not disrespect them like
that okay
jay-z is my favorite we got we got a we
got
a little wayne and biggie and me
oh wait p-i-m-p oh my god you can't get
any more gangster than that
like come at me rappers i am p-i-n-p
i don't know what that was okay come
back come back um
we got an update in the chicken wars
taco bell
is joining the chicken wars with a new
taco
it's a quarter pound white meat double
breaded chicken
breast on a taco a little boy
little poyo i don't know why that's
funny
it's not funny stop me stop doing that
it's not funny
ain't nobody going to taco bell to eat
some god dang puyo tacos
we want to go and we want to eat the
nasty stuff
if we go i want the chalupa that's what
i want
do you want to wait have we told the
people our chimichanga story
i think i'll just tell real quick
anybody ever heard of chimichanga
i was at a restaurant one time and i
said to him and i said
uh what should i get and she was like oh
our chimichangas are good or whatever
and i was like okay and she left and
then i started thinking and i said to
paulina
uh i said something she goes what are
you thinking about i was like i was just
thinking man
jimmy chunga like jimmy must be rich as
hell
and she was like what and i was like
yeah man i've heard of that before so
like obviously like who the hell is
jimmy i'm gonna google it and i went to
pick up my phone and she was dying
she was like what are you doing and i
was like i wonder who the founder is and
she was like
you're an idiot it's not jimmy chunga
she was like there's no jimmy and i was
like oh
got it chimichanga whatever but jimmy
would be rich
jimmy would be taco bell rich he's very
serious he said what do you mean
it's jimmy stronga and i was like i just
like the word uh chalupa
which is not the word and that's what
the doubt they got who
taco bell got chalupa i don't know yeah
they do but now they're trying to make
fried
poryo tacos is stupid
nobody wants that from you give us the
unhealthy stuff try to kill us i want to
go to taco bell and try to kill me
like put it in my body what doesn't kill
me makes me stronger taco bell stop
trying to be
new age nonsense just give me the
unhealthy stuff
all right it's time for ask lunch money
time hashtag
what's the white stuff they'll be
putting on there um uh
not whipping cream no not whipped cream
uh what is it uh on what
on unlike your tacos and stuff you could
get um
ah come on cream wait what it's not
cream cheese that goes on a bagel
wait is it um why can't we not think of
this
like melted cheese is that what you're
trying to say no like when you go
and they're like oh do you want guac or
uh
sour cream sour cream bam bam i knew i
was gonna take it like cream cheese no
you weren't yes i would
i want the sour cream like just coming
down like it's a mountain like we're
going to go skiing just make it
unhealthy just put it all
in there and try to kill me why are you
saying because i haven't been going to
taco bell but if i go to taco bell
try to kill me that should be their
tagline taco bell we try to kill i made
stuffed
uh peppers last night it was all healthy
made a cucumber salad
yeah you could say paulina's kitchen we
try to save your life
then taco bell should be like taco bell
we try to kill you
okay are you done yes okay um
quesadillas are my favorite though oh in
miami there's this place called koyo
taco
very good quesadillas best quesadillas
i've ever had
all right tg okay wait it says lunch
money time hashtag asklm
in the comments below anthony's not
paying attention
we are going to go with tg aka
scream pomp and pimp love the content we
hit the one trillion dollar btc market
captcha what's the most significant
thing you see happening
is a result why are you out of the frame
come back um
so what was the most significant thing i
see happening
i think that i think that
it's gonna a lot more people are gonna
get access to the financial markets i
wrote about the bitcoin etf in canada
this
morning go check it out go be a
subscriber pumpletter.com
but what it basically means is that now
there's more liquidity in the market
more liquidity means more utility more
utility means more interest more
interest means
more demand more demand to a fixed
supply asset means higher prices
self-fulfilling property
all right so joseph pass or passy
um pump hypothetically hypothetical what
would be the implications if all the
economies collectively agreed to take
all of their monetary wealth and convert
it to bitcoin with some kind of fair
conversion
this isn't a question of the price i'm
talking about the implications of a
truly stabilized decentralized system
no more denominating in usd relative to
the old prices do houses get more
expensive bread milk what are the
implications for foreign trade
there are a lot more factors i actually
think one of the craziest things to
think about is it would completely
violate all of the traditional investing
philosophy
because the entire investing philosophy
is don't save invest
that's how you get rich you have to
invest you have to own assets the dollar
gets devalued asset prices go up
if all of a sudden you flip it and
actually investing doesn't actually
bring a increased amount of dollars
instead it's saving and when you go out
of the currency
uh that would be uh one how the world
used to work like i don't know
normal uh but also two is uh it would
change the way that people would have to
think about building wealth
and it would go back to actually running
balanced balance sheets
like literally you couldn't go do all
this crazy stuff
yeah you would have to literally just
make money spend less than you make and
save it's shocking yeah it's so funny
how like all the fundamentals that apply
to individuals don't apply to the
government
and well the government just they can
print whatever money you want i know
that's another
thing around a specific question though
i think that uh it will never happen one
obviously
two is um i do think that it would
drastically change the way that
uh countries finance their economy and
also finance things like war
so i think we would live in a more
prosperous less violent
world and people would be much more
focused on kind of improving themselves
rather than constantly trying to go
and uh and put their lifestyle their
opinions their beliefs their politics
into
other parts of the world interesting
just saying
all right moist moist counter oh moist
what up
i missed you dawg all right day seven of
commenting on every episode of lunch
money until palm gives me a call
i'm not sure if this counts as cereal
because you asked him what his favorite
cereal was last number
but quaker oats would be my breakfast
soup of choice if i was stuck to
one for a year if that doesn't count
then i gotta go with frosted mini wheats
i would have chosen neither of those i'm
going to i just like the fact that he
called it breakfast soup
i'm going coco puffs for a year
would you going
moist i got another question for you
wait you didn't answer my cereal
question
nobody asked me i asked you ah like i
said nobody asked me
anthony what is your breakfast soup of
choice i like raisin bran
jesus yeah raisin bran and then if i get
real crazy give me the lucky charms just
try to kill me lucky charm
try to kill me let's go sign me up uh
i got another question for you moist
what was the logic
what was the logic when you got on
youtube and you were like
i need a username and you were like
i'm gonna use moist that's gonna be my
username moist
and i don't wanna hear a lie i don't
want to hear anything gross
i don't want to hear anything crazy it's
a kid's show but i want to know the
story moist
what was the logic if we're going to
talk to each other
we're going to have to have sound
decision making and the decision
to pick the name moist i feel like
there's a story there
by the way can i just tell you something
i think i encountered moist
on twitter with his real name same photo
i'm not gonna say what it is
i think if that was truly his real name
but anyway
all right that's all i have uh oh moist
i'm not gonna ask
but do not let the detective start
going to work i want to know why you
call yourself moist
we'll see you guys tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends